herzlich willkommen zum wohnungs video
nummer sechs dem projekt indem ich eine
wohnung kaufen die ausreise und nach
meinen und euren träumen renault ihre
probleme fortschritte und der aktuelle
stand erwarten euch in dieser folge ich
wünsche euch eine menge spaß
ganz kurz bevor das video hier startet
wir haben eine neue kollektion mit tarek
released und davon habe ich nie
irgendwas auf youtube erzählt nur auf
instagram über den tabak account also
falls ihr das noch nicht gesehen habt
check den link über die video
beschreibung aus könnte ich ihn hole ihn
t shirt oder eine hose sind sehr nette
sachen dabei und jetzt viel spaß mit dem
video was soll ich euch sagen wir haben
donnerstag den vierten august wir
befinden uns mitten in der aktuellen
projektwoche und es sieht diese rabl aus
es ist tatsächlich zum baustopp gekommen
wir haben nach wie vor keine klare
aussage des hausverwalters wie mit der
kaputten leitung umgehen ob wir daran
jetzt was machen dürfen und das ist sehr
problematisch weil alle weiteren steps
also neue wände zu ziehen im bad
weitermachen im großen raum weitermachen
egal was hängt und dieser doofen leitung
zusammen probleme sind allerdings nur
dornige chancen wie unser cl einst schon
sagte und deswegen haben wir natürlich
trotzdem ein paar stellen gefunden wo
wir doch etwas weitermachen konnten auf
diesem tag habe ich mich jetzt schon
anderthalb wochen gefreut vielleicht
erinnert ihr euch noch an das erste
video wo ich alles rausgerissen habe und
ich gemerkt habe dass ich kein
absperrventil an der heizung habe und
das ist für mich als laien keine
möglichkeit die heizung selber abzubauen
ich habe aber kein eck ventil wo es was
zu drehen kann
wir weitermachen und das 1 1 frü gerät
die einzige möglichkeit ist wie wir das
machen können ist für die leitungen ein
und gibt uns somit die möglichkeit neue
stutzen quasi drauf zu schrauben und die
heizung abnehmen zu können das haben wir
jetzt da und die leitungen werden gerade
schon eingefroren ich finde das super
crazy auch wenn das für jeden sak
menschen natürlich das normalste der
welt ist irgendwie begeistert mich das
und dann können wir gleich die
heizkörper abnehmen und neue ventile
grund rum
[Musik]
der estrich konnte jetzt übrigens noch
komplett im ganzen rathaus das habe ich
im einvernehmen aller arbeitenden
parteien beschlossen und wird neuer
estrich gelegt am anfang hab mir nur
geplant erst im duschbereich auszunehmen
erstmals überall und alle sind happy
damit haben wir uns auch die ganzen
fliesen herauszustellen
tatsächlich wollte ich euch eigentlich
noch gar nicht erzählen wie das bad
aussehen wird aber ich kann es einfach
nicht für mich behalten denn ich bin
ziemlich hat das badezimmer wird nämlich
nicht gefliest wie es einst war und wie
man für gewöhnlichen standard badezimmer
ausstatten würde sondern es wird
fugenlos gefliest
nicht gibt es wirklich gefliest es wird
fugenlos gespachtelt es wird eben nicht
gefliest es wird fugenlos gespachtelt
und das ist ein absolutes highlight für
die wohnung super klima lockt keine
fugen und einfach ein super helles
raumklima das den raum mega zugute kommt
da eher winzig klein ist wie genau das
funktioniert weiß ich nicht dafür werde
ich mir experten abzuholen denen wir
alle fragen stellen können und den wir
dann über die schulter schauen das ist
momentan auch so das begehrteste was man
bekommen kann in super vielen modernen
bädern ist das drin und deswegen hat das
ganze natürlich auch seinen preis und
auch abseits des badezimmers habe ich
für den umbau natürlich eine menge
werkzeug gekauft kleinkram einfach viel
geld ausgegeben und vielleicht kennt ihr
das selber ihr habt etwas gekauft das
eigentlich gar nicht ihrem budget
entspricht und seid jetzt eine
ratenzahlung und einem verbraucherkredit
gefangen aber kein problem empfinden
unterstützen nämlich nicht nur mich und
dieses video sondern auch euch mit eurem
raten oder kreditproblem auf diversen
social media plattform macht es ja
gerade mega die runden mit seinem
beinahe pay later schulden zu flexen was
ich wirklich mit arabischen oberstes
ziel sollte es sein diese loszuwerden
und annie finden ist der absolut erste
richtige schritt in diesem prozess das
gesamte angebot von andy film richtet
sich an leute die bereits in einem
kredit drin hängt also schon verschuldet
sind und wirklich nur an die ihr ladet
euch die app herunter um dort die letzte
raten oder kreditkartenabrechnung
hochzuladen denn ich finde prüft eure
ratenkäufe auf bedingungen und schaut ob
es irgendeine möglichkeit gibt den
kredit günstiger zu machen wenn das der
fall ist und auch wirklich nur wenn das
der fall ist bekommt ihr ein angebot und
könnte dann ganz unverbindlich
entscheiden ob jetzt annehmen wollte
oder nicht das ganze ist komplett
kostenlos und wie gesagt komplett
unverbindlich und falls ihr euch fragt
wie das funktioniert dann habe ich jetzt
die antwort für euch entfernt sorgt
dafür dass der kredit auf einmal ab
bezahlt wird wodurch sich in vielen
fällen ein angebot mit weniger zinsen
machen können gleichzeitig wird es
dadurch deutlich flexibler und ihr könnt
euch selber einstellen in welchem tempo
er die raten zurückzahlen wollte und bis
zu zwei raten pausen im jahr einlegen
und nochmal das gesamte angebot von
entwickeln richtet sich nur an leute die
bereits verschuldet sind und eine
bessere günstigere und flexiblere
lösungen suchen um ihre schulden in den
griff zu bekommen klingt also jetzt auf
den ersten der video beschreibung
benutzt code day für 20 euro rabatt auf
eure erste ratenzahlung und fangt an
euer schlamassel aufzuräumen vielen dank
an die fans für die unterstützung dieses
videos und dieses projekt nur durch
solche partner ist es möglich das ist so
große projekte machen kann deswegen bin
ich super dankbar und ich wünsche euch
viel spaß weiter motivieren es ist zeit
für die tapete dafür habe ich sie
gestern schon angerollt also mit so
einem stachel dingen so kleine löcher
überall in der faser tapete gemacht das
ist echt hartnäckig ich würde sagen wir
haben fünf verschiedene lagen tapete
übereinander deswegen habe ich mir einen
tapeten kraftloser gekauft ihr so ein
spring mit dem ich das ganze gleich
anspringen werde das wird alles verdünnt
und dann wird die wand damit eingesprüht
und dann solltet ihr die tapete quasi
von alleine ankommen wird auch nicht
fast als wäre das hier so was wie spülen
die anderen jungs haben ja auch gesagt
dass man das ziemlich gut mitspielen
hinbekommt aber ich habe keinen spiele
da und ich war gerade im baumarkt also
nehmen wir das
[Musik]
schauen wir mal
und was soll ich sagen es habe mich
tatsächlich vier oder fünf lagen tapete
erwartet und das ganze wurde deutlich
einfacher als ich es eingesprüht und
angefeuchtet habe im trockenen zustand
war das quasi unmöglich die irgendwie
abzubekommen und als die angefeuchtet
waren und durch die löcher die wir
vorher schon da mit reingezogen haben
ging es dann eigentlich relativ 1 also
ich dachte wirklich wir werden jetzt
diverseste tage damit beschäftigt vier
lage tapeten die sich über die letzten
50 jahre fest gebacken haben von den
wänden zu holen diese wand hinter mir
die großflächig sste wand die wir haben
und auch scheinbar die decke sind aber
nur in einer lage und butterweich ab die
briten vielleicht hat jetzt vielleicht
15 minuten gedauert und die winzige
fläche vor dem eingangsbereich hat
gerade eben anderthalb stunden oder so
gedauert also wirklich ein absoluter
segen weil dadurch um zehn den rest der
tapeten mit
tatkräftiger unterstützung von einem
kumpel habe ich dann innerhalb von zwei
oder zweieinhalb stunden die kompletten
tapeten im ganzen raum entfernt etwas
anders sah es dann beim boden aus unter
dem laminat hat uns ja tatsächlich
teppich erwartet der scheinbar
eingeklebt wurde als die wohnung das
erste mal bezogen wurde war zumindest
richtig festgeklebt und wir haben zu
zweit und zentimeter für zentimeter vor
gearbeitet das war wirklich absoluter
payne aber ist raus und jetzt sitze ich
hier spreche zu euch am donnerstag und
warten verzweifelt auf den anruf des
hausverwalters um irgendwie weitermachen
zu können ich will die videos so frisch
wie es geht bringen in der letzten woche
haben wir samstags abgedreht und
sonntags kam das video für euch das will
ich auch gerne weiterhin so machen aber
ich bin halt jetzt gerade dem den
normalen problemen ausgesetzt und ich
hoffe dass ich jetzt noch irgendwas
klärt damit wir den freitag den samstag
und den halben sonntag noch
weiterarbeiten können damit ihr ein
video bekommt in dem es ordentlich
weitergeht vielen dank an alle gewerke
schon mal die dabei sind tatsächlich
sehen jetzt alle an einem strang und
probieren alles möglich zu machen klein
das nicht schon mal ich habe meine kohle
möglichkeit überlegt wie jeder von euch
irgendwann die möglichkeit haben wird
weil der nacht in dieser wohnung zu
schlafen dazu aber in einem weiteren
video mehr
ich kotze wirklich im strahl es ist
wieder eine woche vergangen haben wie da
keine nachricht vom hausverwalter und
beschreiben mittlerweile mittwoch den
zehnten august also es ist wieder eine
woche vergangen wirklich absolut schlimm
wir können nicht weitermachen und sind
absolut die hände gebunden alles was wir
weiter machen konnten haben wir
tatsächlich getan deswegen habe ich den
tischler und den elektriker eingeladen
und wir haben geschaut was in den
nächsten wochen in der wohnung passieren
soll wenn wir uns denn vorher noch an
das rohr wagen
also hier 60 innen hier unten so fläche
für staubsauger und so und ich hätte die
arbeitshöhe von der küche gerne auf
meter 5 metall oder ist es dass
irgendwas ein hackmack für so eine
winzige wohnung habt ihr so was schon
mal gemacht so viel auch an wenn so
einer kleinen buden jetzt ist auch nur
die frage wie schlau das ist dann
fernsehen zu hängen achtung
und dann in einer mietwohnung da
scheißen sie doch auf mich und meinen
fernseher über zwei stunden haben wir in
der wohnung verbracht und in
einvernehmen aller parteien dann
entschieden was wie passieren soll für
die einbaulösungen die der tischler baut
also es kommt eine einbauküche
einbauschrank und ein einbau bett haben
wir uns für sachen entschieden wo er
wirklich auch selber neue wege gehen
muss neue beschläge suchen muss neue
griffe suchen muss neue möglichkeiten
sucht weil ich sachen angefragt habe die
man eigentlich so nicht macht weil sie
komplett viel zu teuer sind viel zu
aufwendig aber ich glaube genau das
brauchen wir in so einer kleinen wohnung
wenn wir jeden zentimeter nutzen wollen
außerdem haben wir eine lösung gefunden
wie wir die waschmaschine in der wohnung
platzieren können wenn wir uns an folge
eins oder zwei zurück erinnern war das
ja ein problem das wir im keller keinen
platz für eine waschmaschine haben die
wird jetzt mit in die wohnung integriert
das ist megageil das bett hat ein zwei
kleine tricks und allgemein gibt es ein
paar lösungen die wir gefunden haben die
richtig richtig special sind elektriker
und tischler waren zum selben zeitpunkt
da weil natürlich auch
elektroinstallationen in den schrank mit
eingebaut werden und der elektriker ist
nicht nur elektriker sondern auch
lichtgestalter eigentlich für viel
größere projekte aber haben sich erbarmt
für mich und dieses winzige projekt
einmal zu zeigen was sie so drauf haben
und da haben wir uns auch unfassbar
neuesten sachen überlegt dafür haben wir
auch eine lösung gefunden wird
tatsächlich diese woche weiter machen
können und quasi um die leitungen
drumherum arbeiten das ist so ziemlich
das einzige was jetzt in den nächsten
wochen ohne reparierte leitung passieren
kann und darum wird es nicht im nächsten
video drehen also komplett wände
aufstemmen neue leitungen zu
verteilungskämpfen und so weiter das
kommt alles im nächsten video aber ja
was soll ich sagen es ist alles nicht so
friede freude eierkuchen wie ich es mir
vorgestellt habe ich bin dem
hausverwalter komplett ausgesetzt der
hausverwalter hat ein angebot von
unserem sak betrieb ihm ist es aber zu
hoch oder ihm passt es nicht wie auch
immer ich habe seit fünf oder sechs
tagen nichts mehr von ihm gehört seit
fünf oder sechs tagen steht die
baustelle still und fünf oder sechs tage
gibt es weniger wohnraum deswegen in
köln das ist komplett quatsch und ich
hasse es aber das gehört eben auch mit
dazu und damit zeichne ich zumindest ein
etwas reales bild als das was man sonst
vielleicht auf youtube sieht wenn euch
das video trotz der ganzen probleme
genauso viel spaß gemacht hat wie mir
beim drehen dann lass ihn gerne ein
leichter vergess ich den kanal zu
abonnieren und freut euch auf
hoffentlich ein neues video am sonntag
wenn wir neue informationen haben neue
elektroleitungen gezogen sind und wir
irgendwie weiterkommen macht es gut bis
in den nächsten tagen
[Musik]